소울을 추출하는 프로젝트를 같이 만들어볼 거예요
소울이 저희 소울인가요?
네 여러분의 소울은 이제 회사 것입니다
오오오오
판교에 있으면 사실 제일 중요한 게 많은 분들이
이게 얼마나 높냐
아
관심 많이 가지시잖아요
으음
으으음
내려올 때 천천히 내려올 때 천천히
멈춰 스톱
봐봐 봐봐 봐봐 어깨에 봐
어차피
야 뭐야 이거 숭애야 잠깐만
니니야
오늘은 직장인이 돼서
네
브이로그를 찍는 겁니다
제 2의 여의도로 불리는
판교의
판교 테크노밸리
판교 테크노밸리니까 테크노 춤을
따 딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱
아니 근데 지금
출근하신다는 분이
호주머니에 손 딱 넣고
네
지금 이렇게 거만한 태도로 가도 되는 겁니까?
아 몰랐군요
저는 임원
자네는 쫄따고
아닐 텐데
같은 사원으로 입사하는 거예요
어 나
전달을 잘못 받은 거야
나 임원 해준다고 그랬는데
아니 근데 슈카님 도대체
회사를 몇 개를 입사를 하시는 거예요
광고 들어올 때마다
재입사를 하시는 것 같아
아 떨린다
야 근데 사람이
너무 많아서
좀 쪽팔리는데
저쪽으로 가자.
많은 사람들이 알아봐서 브이로그 못 짓겠다.
와...
짠.
어? 가짠가?
왜 안 되는데?
이거 사후쯤 되면 되는 거 아닌가요?
혹시 어디 클럽인데요?
촬영 왔는데요.
카카오페이 증권.
열어주셨어요.
아 진짜? 모르시는 분한테 물어보면 어떡해.
어 뭐야? 잠깐만.
사장님이 왜 여기 왜 있어요.
아니야. 대표니까 오늘은.
안녕하세요.
오늘 제 비서 역할이십니까? 아니면 윗분 역할이십니까?
인턴으로 들어오셨다고.
제가요?
사운드 아니고 인턴이었어요?
오늘 역할이?
총무팀 메이슨이라고.
오 메이슨.
헬로 메이슨?
저희는 이제 님 자는 안 쓰고 앞에 이름만.
슈카 출근하셨어요?
슈카!
너 몇 살이냐?
간단하게 그 장비랑 오피스 투어.
아 예예.
네.
가고 있습니다.
위에는 보시다시피.
오 멋있다.
시세판.
잠깐만 지금 이거 실시간이에요?
네. 실시간이에요.
어 뭐 마이너스 10% 잠깐만.
죄송한데 업무 중에 주식 확인 좀 하지 말아주세요.
아 근데 이게 장점이자 단점이네요.
어 이건 뭡니까 여기는?
아 플레이전이라고 저희 크루들 일하다가 스트레스 받으시거나 좀 머리 식힐 때.
잠깐만 동작 그만.
실제로 여기서 하시는 분 있어요?
없죠. 이런 거.
많아요.
어 잠깐만.
저희는 그냥 자유롭게.
아 눈치 안 보고?
네. 눈치 주지도 않고.
그리고 이쪽은.
죄송한데 그 왜 길이 월스트리트인가요?
월스트리트 있고 여기는 센트럴파크.
아 여기 센트럴파크입니다?
맞습니다. 반대편은 팔로알토.
오 팔로알토고.
실리콘밸리까지 있어요.
월스트리트 한번 가보도록 하자.
아 월스트리트.
판교의 월스트리트.
진짜 월스트리트 갈 때네.
따라라라따 너무 좋아 어떡해 벌써 좋아.
나 저거 진라면 좋아하는데.
무슨 월스트리트에 라면을 팔아요?
큰 건 아니지만 그래도 작게나마 저희 편의점 이렇게 여기까지가 저희 편의시설 투어였습니다.
아 제 자리 가는 거 아니었습니까?
이제는 이제 자리로.
제 자리.
방이 단독방입니까?
이상하게 골방으로 가는 거 같은데요?
아니 우리.
가두는 거 아니야 제이스?
메이슨입니다.
아 메이슨.
메이슨 우리가 창피해요.
잠깐 골방으로 가두는 거 같은데.
하와이로 모셔요.
아 하와이로 모셔요?
아니 우리도 다른 직원보다 같이 일하고 싶은데 골방에 가는 거 같은데.
여기 혹시 임원실.
비슷합니다.
아 좀 어렵겠는데요.
처음 오셨으니까 재밌게 즐기시는데 그래도 열심히 화이팅 하시길 바라겠습니다.
죄송한데 문 닫고 좀 떠들어주세요.
아 진짜 오늘.
이걸로 출입은 비록 실제로는 못했지만.
이거 이거 이거.
하나 둘 셋.
찰칸.
이게 브이로그 할 때 이런 게 있어야 되잖아.
하와이 카카 회의 직원에서 인사 드려요.
아우 여기 지금 시차가 있어서 적응이 좀 괜찮아요.
온보딩 교육을 먼저 해드릴 거거든요.
와 진짜 나 입사한 거 같아.
저희 팀에서 어떤 식으로 일하고 지금 AI 상황이 어떻고 그런 거에 대해서 짤막하게 설명을 드리려고 합니다.
근데 이름이 진짜 AI 서비스 센터 맞아요?
혹시 그 사내에서 AI 센터 아니냐고 하시면서.
아니라고.
일단 배경부터 한 번 설명을 드리면 좋은 소식과 나쁜 소식이 있거든요.
좋은 소식은 기술이 다 준비가 됐다.
이거를 어떻게 활용하느냐.
백지 같은 아이라고 생각하시면 되고.
나쁜 소식은 뭐냐면 알아서 모든 걸 뚝딱 할 수는 없거든요.
자기의 시간을 써서 얘를 트레이닝하는 그런 희생이 필요하다.
이 축하 친구들 입장에서 대단히 중요한 질문이 하나 있습니다.
이걸 잘 교육시키면 좀 줄일 수 있는.
미국의 빅테크나 아니면 월스트리트의 해지펀트 매니저나 컨설팅 업계를 보면.
AI랑 같이 일하라고.
해놓고 그 사람의 일하는 방식이라고 추출을 한 다음에.
그분들을 대체하는 일이 실제로 생기고 있거든요.
아직도 증권사 다녔으면 짤렸을 수도 있겠다.
무슨 소리야 지금.
대체한다고 그러잖아 매니저들도.
그래서 오늘 온보딩 끝난 다음에 해보려고 하는 게.
두 분의 암묵지를 추출을 해서.
진짜로 대체 될 수 있냐?
일할 수 있는지 한 번 데모를 해보는.
저 집이 하나의 작업 공간이라고 생각을 하시면.
src라고 돼 있는 거는 소스 코드거든요.
닥스라고 돼 있는 건 프로젝트에 대한 문서들.
예전에는 저게 다 분리돼 있고.
합치거나 그랬다면.
저희가 테스트해보고 있는 것 중에 하나는.
한 공간에서 저걸 다 하는 거예요.
저렇게 되면 어떻게 되냐.
AI가 저걸 다 보고 있거든요.
감시하고 있어요?
감시 목적은 아니고.
AI가 지금 이 팀에서 벌어지고 있는 일들을.
다 숙지로 하고 있는 거죠.
다나가 오늘 편집한 영상.
A B C D.
어제 슈카는 하스스톤을 3시간 했고.
일을 1시간 했고.
하지만 그는 사장입니다.
이렇게 돼 있죠.
이걸 또 한 번 이렇게.
순서대로 정리를 해보면.
스마트머니 TF의 PM이고.
이 뭘 할지.
그런 걸 이제.
요구사항이라고.
요구사항이라고 하는데.
요구사항을 정리를 해둔 다음에.
월터.
신입사원이 딴짓하고 있습니다.
이러면서 딴짓하고 있어.
딴짓.
공부 얘기 너무 깁니다.
다.
기록되고 있습니다.
AI가 다.
잠깐만.
AI가.
AI가 자네가 지금 뭐 했는지.
딱 기억하고 있어요.
애쓸데가 없는 짓 한 거.
근데 오늘 월터의 의상을 보니까.
믿음이 갑니다.
아.
네.
헬로우 키티.
일단 이분 개발자들은.
이상하게 개발자들은.
이렇게 좀 덕후스러운 분들이.
많다는 썰이 있던데.
이거.
덕후는 아니고요.
제가 이거를.
아끼는 옷이긴 한데.
제.
아내의 취향이 좀.
네.
들어가 있는.
그 아내는 그.
리얼 월드에 계시는 분이시죠?
아내가.
자기에 대해서.
자세한 얘기는 또.
밖에서 하지.
아.
하셔드리시죠.
3D 일 수도 있고.
2D 일 수도 있고.
예. 알겠습니다.
오늘 해볼 건 뭐냐면.
두 분의 안묵질을 추출해서.
일을 시켜보는.
소울을 추출하는 프로젝트를.
같이 만들어 볼 거예요.
소울이.
저희 소울인가요?
네. 이제.
내 영혼을 지금.
오.
빨려 들어가는 거예요?
네. 여러분의 소울은.
이제 회사 것입니다.
그런 식으로.
카카오페이징권에.
내 소울이 들어가는 거예요?
니니.소울을.
오른쪽에 보시면.
파일이라는.
공간이 있거든요.
네.
저기에 올려볼까요?
뭐 슈카.
니니의.
성격이 어떤지.
성격이요?
이 첨부 파일에.
있는.
성격이 어떤지.
요약해줘.
그렇게 해보세요.
아니 아니.
미리.
지금 넣는 거 아니고요.
아니 조작.
조작하는 게 아니라.
아니 성격을.
넣으라고 해서 넣는 줄 알았죠.
그게 아니고.
슈카의 성격은 착하고 이러고 있어요.
AI가 알고 있는.
성격이 어떤지.
한번 확인해 보려고 하는 겁니다.
와.
근데 여기 보면은.
직설적이고.
호기심 폭발하고.
맞아.
창피하지 않고.
이해될 때까지.
너무 똑똑하구나.
두 분이 생각하시는.
본인과 다른 부분.
그런 부분을.
채팅으로.
설명해서.
수정하시면 됩니다.
개미들의 투자에.
적극 공감하는.
따뜻하고.
따뜻한 게 몇 번 들어가면.
얼마나 차가우면.
따뜻한 걸 지금 두 번이나 넣어요.
인간미 넘치는.
언어를.
사용한다.
자유가.
왜요.
아니 이 사람 진짜 이상해요.
자꾸 조작해요.
뭘 조작해.
내가 내 성격 넣는 건데.
아니 어떻게 자기를.
슈카는 너무 차갑지 않고.
따뜻한 표현을 사용한다.
인간미 넘치는 언어를 사용한다.
맞잖아요.
가끔.
비주얼로.
승부함.
됐습니다.
그 파일을 한번 읽어보세요.
마음에 들게 나왔는데.
가끔 비주얼로 승부한다.
아.
말로만 설명하기.
복잡한 구조.
흐름 비교가 나오면.
표 도시파.
다이어그램을 적극 활용한다.
비주얼이 이 비주얼이었는데.
얼굴로 승부한다고 그랬더니.
이 비주얼은 안 된다라고.
벌써 자세 파악을 한 겁니까.
제가 추정하면.
AI가.
슈카님을.
이미 알고 있어요.
모른 척 하는구나.
와.
얘.
똑똑해.
이제는 뭘 해볼 거냐면.
추출한 소울을 가지고.
앱에 넣어볼 예정입니다.
제 영혼을 저기다 넣어요?
저희 거니까 이제.
네?
에?
저희 거니까 이제.
잠깐만.
들어가 보면.
오 뭐야.
저 아래에 있는 정보는.
카카오페이 증권이 제공하는 건데.
말하는 걸 슈카식.
니니식으로 말해준다는 거죠?
맞습니다.
하나씩 해볼까요?
어떤 거 해볼까요?
종목 분석?
종목 분석 좋습니다.
어차피 지금은.
실제 데이터로 하는 게 아니라.
이 데이터도.
AI가 가짜로 생산한 거거든요.
68,300원.
너무 사고 싶다.
와.
우와 우와.
슈카의 한마디.
좋은 회사와.
지금 사야 할 주식은.
다를 수 있습니다.
목적에 따라 전략은.
완전히 달라질 수 있습니다.
슈카 스타일로.
딱 얘기해 주시네.
니니님 걸로.
한 번 또 해볼까요?
초보 체크리스트를 한 번 해볼까요?
준비된 재미는 다른데.
얘 얘기할 때 맨날 앞에.
헛.
앗.
이런 거 붙여요.
그거 언제적 리액션이야.
헛.
회사에서 투입되신 다음에.
이런 제품들을 만드는 거죠.
AI 에이전트 발전 속도.
이게 사실은 작년에만 해도.
이런 얘기가 별로 안 나왔던 것 같거든요.
1년 만에 완전히.
천지개벽한 얘기들이 나오고 있는데.
올해도 보면.
엔트로픽의 매출이.
한 달에 두 배씩 늘고 있더라고요.
와.
그래서.
굉장한 속도로.
부끄럽다.
늘고 있다.
두 분이.
굉장히 집중하는 게.
눈에 보여가지고.
제가 이제.
설명드리면서.
뿌듯했고요.
보람도 있었고.
잘 하실 것 같아요.
지금.
AI 에 대한 경험이.
두 분이.
많지는 않은 것 같거든요.
하지만.
AI 가 도와줄 수가 있다.
윌슨 아저씨 너무 말이 많아가지고.
너무 힘들었어요.
오늘 일은 어떠신.
어떠셨나요?
힘들어요.
조금 쉬어야 될 것 같아요.
우리 일을 너무 많이 해가지고.
매점 있으니까.
컵라면이라도 하나 때리자.
저는 이걸로 먹겠습니다.
그러면 여기.
온 김에.
사장님이.
좋아하는 과자.
좀 얘기 좀 해주세요.
아.
달달구리.
그놈의 달달구리.
진짜.
알상무님.
맨날 이런 거.
크림빵.
이런 거.
맨날 먹고.
싸니까.
좀 많이 사도 돼요?
나도.
아이스크림 먹어야겠다.
595.
너무 싸다.
누가 웃는데.
야.
바코드.
어디든지.
계산할.
모를 수도 있지.
우리 아빠도.
이런 거.
잘 알았는데.
요즘에.
오케이.
이제.
이거 하나 몰고.
우리 게임하러 갑시다.
플레이전.
자.
게임 한 번 하자.
여기 골프 있어.
골프.
이거 폼 한 번 보여주세요.
사장님.
나이스 샷.
올라갈 때.
응.
팔이 그대로.
음.
올라가면서.
이거 들고.
응.
이렇게.
이렇게 치면.
일로 갈 거 같잖아요.
너 진심모드.
네.
아니.
일로 갈 거 같잖아.
진짜로.
이걸 힘으로.
딱 치는 게 아니라.
여기서.
저거리 가려면.
열리면.
이 정도 되면 돼.
멀면 이렇게.
아니.
죄송한데.
혹시.
여기 누구.
물어본 사람.
아니.
그렇다고.
왜.
자꾸.
오.
자.
이렇게 하면.
세다는 거죠.
높이를 알라는 거야.
나.
겁나.
잘 치는 줄 알았네.
그걸 알려주는 거지.
지나가야.
들어간다.
파.
짧으면 안 돼.
아.
왜 안 돼.
이렇게 짧으면.
안 들어간다는 거죠.
하나.
둘.
셋.
파.
빠샷.
점심을.
간단하게 먹고.
땀을 내가지고.
회사 근처에 있는.
헬스장에 왔습니다.
아.
실컷이에요.
제가 옛날에.
벤치 좀 쳤기 때문에.
와.
벤치 오려면.
차 한번 쳐보려고 왔습니다.
이거 몇 킬로예요?
10킬로?
이거.
이게 50킬로짜리고.
이게 50킬로짜리여서.
도합 110킬로 정도 됩니다.
뭐야.
10킬로.
나도 들지.
자.
뭐라고요?
한번 보여주세요.
우리 벤치 칠 때.
제가 자세히 알려드릴게요.
어.
알려주세요.
이거.
기록.
근데 이거.
배가 너무.
아니.
그게 아니라.
일부러 들어야 돼.
이렇게.
아치.
아치 모양으로.
왜.
쳤는데.
기록을 위해서.
이거.
뛰어.
흡.
음.
오.
뭐야.
가볍게 되네.
음.
오.
여기를 타겟으로.
네.
거기 힘 딱 주는 걸로.
거기에.
오케이.
아.
무거워.
내려올 때 천천히.
멈춰.
스톱.
그리고 천천히.
후.
오케이.
이렇게 오늘 또 쌓인 피로를 한번 풀어주는.
피로가 쌓이는 것 같은데.
더.
더 쌓여.
어우.
힘들어.
그냥 어깨를 보여줘야 되는데.
아.
어깨를 보여줘야 돼?
자신있어? 어깨?
어깨? 어깨 만지..
그러면 적당히 좀 편집을 해봐
어깨를 궁금해 할 것 같아
봐봐 봐봐 봐봐
어깨에만
어차피..
뭐야 이게 숭이야 잠깐만
어때?
이거 노딱?
아 노딱이야?
아 안되겠다
슈퍼님 있을 때 천국에다 있었나요?
아니 있긴 있었는데
이건 전 잘 안했어요
저는 레벨 5로 가거든요
너무 빡세게 하면 오래 못해서
자 천국으로 가십시오
오오오오오오오
할아버지 할머니 속도로 가는 거 같은데?
근데 이렇게 점심시간에 짬 내서
한 30분이라도 하고
오후 업무에 활력이 좀 돌거든요
그래서 여러분들도
이 방법 한번 추천을 드리도록 하겠습니다
아휴 좀 쉬러 나왔는데
아유 카카오페이징권이
저희 직원분들
한 번 궁금한 게 있어요
네네
아 혹시 그 컨셉이 지금
재밌지 않나요?
어 그니까
선배님 이렇게
선배님
헤이디도
헤이디 선배님 안녕하세요
카카오페이징권에서는
이 선배하고 얘기할 때
다리를 꽈도 됩니까?
아 그럼 물론입니다
저희는
어 상관없는데
아 상관없어요?
네 상관없는데
네
판교에 있으면 사실 제일 중요한 게
많은 분들이
이게 얼마나 이게 높냐
이런 거 좀 관심 많이 가지시잖아요
이 여의도도 이게 좀
괜히 높기 높은 곳이거든요
어 그쵸 그쵸 높죠
근데 판교도 이게 좀 높잖아요
상중하 이 어디 정도에
뭐 사람마다 다르겠지만
그래도
OOO은 있지 않을까 조심스레
왜냐면 저희가 또 따로
월마다 해외 주식을 한 33만 원씩
에?
월에 33만 원을 준다고요?
맞아요
그러면은 사실 증권사 다니시는 분들은
수익률이 너무 좋을 것 같거든요
내가 증권사 10년 다녀봤는데 못해
아니야 몰라 또 몰라
은지 증권사 다니면
해야 될 것 같은 압박감이 생겨
정보도 많고 일단
자기도 모르게 그래서 압박감에 끌려서
조금 무리하게 되는 케이스가 이제 좀 많아요
제가 듣기로는
증권사 다니시는 분들은
대박 아니면 레버리지로 쪽박치 하시는 분들이
그렇게 많다고
요즘에 어쨌든 전쟁 때문에 좀 변동성이 많았잖아요
그래서 저도 이제 포지션을 바꾼다고
매수랑 매도를 막 많이 했는데
지금 카카오페이 증권에서
매도 수수료 캐시백 이벤트를 하고 있다 보니까
오 그거는 직원들만 해주는 거예요?
어 아니요 이거는 지금
일반 고객분들 모두 참여할 수 있도록 열어놨습니다
얼마를 돌려주는 거예요?
매도하시는 금액만큼이죠
그 기간 제한 있어요?
기간은 3개월로 제한이 있습니다
오 괜찮다
지금 갑자기 괜찮다 생각했는데
규모가 좀 크면 수수료가 너무 비싸요 수수료가
지금 좋겠는데
잠깐 수수료 사실 잘 안 보거든요
몇 달에 한 번씩 이렇게 보면
꽤 많잖아요
생각보다 크게 나요
왜냐하면 조 단위로 움직이시는 분이기 때문에
저 경 단위로 움직여요?
지난달까지는 조였는데 바꿨어요?
나이가 중요한 건 아닌데
불편하죠
근데 너무 일을 안 하고 노는 거 아닐까요?
지금이 오후 5시인가요?
오늘 이렇게 해 떠 있을 때 사실 퇴근하는 게 굉장히 어렵네요
지금 새벽 3시 아니었어?
AI로 소울이 빨리 느낌이에요
판교 라이프는 오늘 여기까지 한번 해볼게요
퇴근하자
퇴근하자 진짜
자 판교에서 퇴근하는 멋진 모습
힘들어 오늘 신분당선 타고 강남 갑시다
아 힘들어